llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en france 24 para ello contamos con
nuestra periodista especializada daniela
blandón daniela buenas noches y vamos a
comenzar hablando de las sanciones que
se han impuesto hoy contra rusia de qué
se trata
hola rodrigo muy buenas noches pues
miren la respuesta al reconocimiento que
hizo el kremlin de la independencia de
las repúblicas separatistas del dow paz
generó respuestas de varias partes como
ya lo hemos visto la unión europea tomó
la delantera este miércoles esperaba
aprobar definitivamente un paquete de
sanciones que incluyen a la prohibición
de entrada a su territorio de altos
funcionarios rusos un embargo comercial
contra la uned y lugansk y también el
límite al acceso de los mercados
financieros y eso lo que hace es
dificultar que se pueda financiar o
financiar su deuda mejor en europa por
otro lado eeuu hizo lo propio también
castigó la deuda rusa y dijo que habrá
más medidas contra las élites de este
país y sus familiares también anunció el
bloqueo de dos bancos el de desarrollo y
el militar escuchamos que dijo el
presidente yo vote
esto quiere decir que le cortamos al
gobierno ruso el financiamiento
occidental ya no puede ir a buscar
dinero en occidente y no puede negociar
nueva deuda en nuestro mercado y el
europeo y reino unido- también hizo lo
propio congeló los activos de cinco
bancos rusos y a tres oligarcas les
prohibió el ingreso al país canadá
también impuso sanciones
daniela creo que otra de las medidas
tiene que ver con el controvertido
gasoducto nord stream 2 cómo puede
afectar a rusia pero digo mire el gran
paso sin duda al odio alemania porque su
canciller o la fashion's les dijo que lo
digo hoy que no otorgará a rusia por
ahora la certificación del caso de ducto
que ya está construido pero que sigue
pendiente de la certificación por parte
de este país
este es un tubo rodrigo diseñado para
duplicar el envío de gas de rusia a
alemania por el mar báltico sin tener
que pasar por ucrania y por eso se ha
vuelto al centro de la disputa porque
eeuu cree que va a aumentar la
dependencia energética que tiene europa
de rusia los planes de crear una vía
para que el gigante ruso gazprom se
ahorrará el pago de derechos al no tener
que pasar justamente por polonia y por
ucrania se fraguaron en una época de
excelentes relaciones entre rusia y
alemania- que fue en 2005 pero el nuevo
canciller ha sido un férreo opositor del
proyecto rodrigo por tanto daniela
cuéntanos a quién afectan concretamente
todas estas medidas pues la unión
europea dice que su paquete de sanciones
afecta a 27 personas y entidades así
como a los 300 de 51 miembros del
parlamento ruso que votaron a favor del
reconocimiento de independencia de estas
repúblicas separatistas del este
ucraniano pero las medidas en general
podrían afectar tanto al que las recibe
que es rusia como al que las imponen que
es oxidante por ejemplo al cerrar el
sistema financiero ruso también se ponen
en aprietos los bancos más expuestos
como italia francia y austria que
mantienen negocios bastante cercanos con
sus pares rusos y en el caso del nord
stream 2 rusia representa el 27 por
ciento de las importaciones de crudo el
41% de las de gas natural en la unión
europea así que frenarlo no le conviene
a ninguno de los dos con esta crisis de
todas maneras ya varios líderes han
hecho un llamado para buscar
alternativas de suministro escucharnos y
sin gastos sporting en gas prices twitch
la inestabilidad del precio del gas los
picos en el precio del gas al que las
economías europeas son tan vulnerables
es una consecuencia del fracaso de
liberarnos de esa dependencia eso es lo
que tenemos que hacer ahora cortar el
cordón umbilical que nos ata al norte
a wall street
pues rodrigo esta no es una tarea nada
fácil porque rusia es el mayor
exportador de gas del mundo y es el
segundo mayor exportador de petróleo
después de arabia saudita y quien no
figura casualmente en ninguna de las
sanciones es el propio presidente ruso
vladimir putin
bastante curioso ese dato nos vamos
ahora hasta las bolsas daniela como les
ha afectado toda esta tormenta política
o street cerró con descensos superiores
al 1 por ciento en línea con los
mercados asiáticos las principales
bolsas europeas es sin embargo borraron
las pérdidas del inicio de la jornada
incluso algunas de ellas lograron
pequeños avances acabamos con la cifra
del día de que se trata pues uno de los
más afectados con toda esta crisis ha
sido el precio del petróleo que está a
punto de tocar la barrera psicológica de
los 100 dólares por barril la cotización
frente de europa cerró el martes en poco
más de 96 dólares y el w 92 35 dólares
la cifra del día hasta aquí este repaso
a la actualidad económica sigan
conectados con nosotros
[Música]